يعود مصطفى من عمله حاملا بعد احتياجات
المنزل الغذائيه تقاعد مصطفى منذ شهور
لكنه اضطر للعوده الى العمل مع ارتفاع
كلفه المعيشه
عائدات مصطفى الماليه ليست هزيله مقارنه
مع ملايين المواطنين الاتراك العاملين
بالحد الادنى للاجور
التضخم كارثه رغم معاش التقاعدي وراتب
الذي يتقاضاه من عمل الجديد فان الحصول
على الاساسيات لم يعد سهلا الذهاب في عطله
بات امرا صعبا صوتنا سيكون لمن لديه خطط
حقيقيه لخفض التضخم
تجرى الانتخابات المقبله بالتزامن مع موجه
غلاء فاحش تعاني منها البلاد جراء التضخم
واستمرار انخفاض قيمه الليره التركيه امام
العملات الرئيسيه
يدرك حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم حجم
الخطر الذي يشكله ملف الاقتصاد على فرص
الرئيس بالفوز في الانتخابات لذلك
ركز في اطلاق حملته الانتخابيه على اعلان
برنامج انتخابي مليء بالوعود الاقتصاديه
لا يمكن التغاضي عما قام به حزبنا في
العقدين الماضيين مشكلتنا الوحيده هي
التضخم نسعى الى خفضه على مراحل وعبر
سياسه اقتصاديه تعتمد زياده الانتاج
والمعروض في قطاعات الغذاء والعقارات
والطاقه
تركز المعارضه في حملاتها على الاقتصاد
ايضا اذ تعتبر التضخم من ابرز النتائج
السيئه لاداره الرئيس الاقتصاديه واحد اهم
الابواب التي قد تقودها الى الحكم
نتفقد المحاله التجاريه وما نسمعه من
مواطنين هو الشكوى نتيجه انخفاض القدره
الشرائيه جراء تضخم سنواجه ذلك عبر وقف
العصابات المتحكمه باقتصادنا وتشكيل اداره
تعتمد النظم الاقتصاديه الواقعيه
يعد الملف الاقتصادي هو مك
افحه اعاده هو رزقه هو لقمه عيشه ما قد
يلعب دورا حاسما في تحديد هويه الفائز
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
المعتز بالاحسن الجزيره انقره